hi everyone my name is Victoria Jackson
from Saturday Night Live and this is
Tamara's never seen it today I'm
watching you f H uhm I did not know that
this was a thing I am NOT not a fan of
Weird Al at all I think he's great but I
didn't like grow up with Weird Al I know
a lot of people did and so I had no idea
that he had a movie somebody on my
patreon wanted me to review this and
then sent it to me in my Pico
so like made it extremely easy for me to
watch and then Doug so that I should do
it one day and asked if I'd seen it and
and now I'm dressed up as Victoria
Jackson from Saturday Night Live Weird
Al looks so much like Doug in these
photos they're spatulas on the Front's
secrets of the universe a mop fish
circle fish okay let's do it
[Music]
you
damnit I should have dressed up like
Fran she's so fabulous this was better
than I thought it was going to be by far
there were a few moments that kind of
felt like oh well I bet no was that just
already a music video and then they just
kind of put it in here the first half
really didn't do anything for we like
character wise at the very beginning his
character is kind of just a lazy kid who
just you know oh I am so imagine it too
my imagination is too much for Edna's
big burger at the joint and it's like
well yeah everyone's imagination I bet
isn't too big for that not no shade
towards people who work at fast-food
restaurants but I you know it's no one's
dream I don't think and so it was just
kind of like you're not special man
you're just kind of lazy but you really
get to know this character and and all
the other characters and I loved it it
again it started off and there are a few
jokes that were really really landing
and I would give a hearty laugh every
like five jokes but there's jokes just
after joke after joke after joke after
joke but once they really get into their
groove at the TV station channel 62 or
whatever once they really get into that
groove it's so flippin good the jokes
are amazing any time that they're doing
it what are their original shows I'm all
I'm all in I'm bored check Tamara's here
Tara's here for it I would watch the
crap out of that television network I
don't have cable so I wouldn't but I
would you to MIT I would subscribe I
would hit that Velma
vacation I would like every video while
you're at it like this video alone it
just feels like I'm not sure of course
this is what it would be like if Weird
Al did like TV parodies or movie
parodies versus song parodies sure this
agent it made a ton of sense like the
Indiana Jones opening scene it's so
funny how the Oscar and all the signs
and there's just so many things that
work so well there's so many details in
this one small little sequence
I bet writing this movie was a complete
blast
Indiana Jones just whipped a guy's arm
off also he looks just like Doug Walker
if Doug Walker had afro they look so
similar I don't know why I've never put
that together but they look identical to
each other also very similar style of
comedy too so it just was kind of like I
was watching like my friends make
something which is fun even if your
friends don't look like Doug Walker I
feel like you could if you're friends
with people who make things and are
creative humans I feel like you might
get that from it too just kind of feels
like I'm just watching friends then they
put a hot dog in a Twinkie with Cheez
Whiz
I want to be mad at it I do I want to be
furious
seething mad but I also I want to try it
I do want to have a bite of it I love
hot dogs and Cheez Whiz I don't love
Twinkies but I feel like with salt and
Mike I think the biggest laugh that I
got out of the whole movie was when he
drops the dog in a punch bowl I loved it
I can't help it I loved to see his uncle
somehow gets a TV station by like a
gambling match a gambling game he
Gamble's and wins TV stations somehow
and lo and behold he doesn't have to
work at the burger store anymore because
he gets to run this TV station
it's funny how that works out in the
movie I wasn't sure how I was gonna feel
about the story upfront up front I was
like ah mm-hmm I could probably go
without the story and just watch these
little vignettes because the throwaway
jokes are hilarious all the commercials
they play are so flippin good I'm going
to club a seal if somebody doesn't cook
a pizza mix that word by car that's so
freakin funny spatula City is this place
that only sells spatulas and it was
hilarious
it was such a good commercial it reminds
me of this place in the suburbs of
Chicago it's called barstools etc and
it's got to be a drug front right you
only sell barstools and whatever etc is
though I did buy my bar stools from bar
stools etc because I was so curious I
went in and the etc by the way is just
movie posters framed movie posters not
signed or anything they're just like
generic shitty Amazon purchases that
they put in frames and they're thriving
I love it we get Kramer I don't I never
watched Seinfeld I know
I'm uncultured swine but he was
hilarious in this and this is before
Seinfeld right now in the nineties what
right right Frasier Doug and Rob quote
that a lot they're trying to get a TV
station up and running and so they have
some some guests on and they have this
guy who's teaching you how to solve wood
and he sauce his finger off and it's
hilarious it's so simple
he calls himself a Butterfinger and like
there's blood all over he's like oh my
face is red it's just it's consistent
joke after joke after joke and it's
really well done they're not gaining
very much traction
weird right then Kramer jumps on in
weird Alstead George's stead and just
kick starts the entire channel because
he's nuts and people love him Stanley
they love Stanley's corner Playhouse or
whatever it's called it's so so fun to
watch he's absolutely nuts in this movie
he's like I've seen a couple episodes of
Seinfeld he's he's he's he's like Kramer
but just dialed up a million notches
they come up with more ideas after
Stanley's funhouse blows up and they've
got wheel of fish which is hilarious
it's so funny they've got growls Wild
Kingdom great Conan the librarian
hilarious I've never seen Conan the
Barbarian but I will vouch that Conan
the librarian is great
now I'm praying then they get the news
their channels somehow is number one in
all of the charts and that is when I
started to really feel for the
characters not that I and I'd argue in
movies like this you don't really need
to feel for the characters it's like a
throwaway joke joke after joke after
joke just like newbie that rules
and is fun but you're not there to like
fall in love with these characters but
they get the news that they're number
one and I was like I've searched all
love with these characters so the rest
of the story is that the station gets
sold to the mean boss guy who says good
out and then they have to raise $75,000
to save him from getting it they parody
Rambo I think I've never seen Rambo but
I'm pretty sure that's what they were
parading parody it'd be one joke really
stood out to me I don't know that it
would be in a movie now so it's a little
racist but hilariously so I think I'm
out of the supply closet and say
surprise but it sounds like supplies cuz
they're Asian it was funny they make the
money and a man his girlfriend Harry get
back together and Stanley gets rescued
and the bad guys get what's coming to
them in the most 80s Early 90s way
possible it had such good moments it
didn't drag it was so silly but I was
kind of expecting that but I wasn't
expecting to enjoy it as much as I did
it was great
some of the movie references may go over
your head but you'll kind of get them
yeah absolutely hilarious the parodies
will make you wants to make parodies
yeah yes that's totally what it is I
think I would have enjoyed it
way more which I really enjoyed it but I
think I would have enjoyed it even more
if I would have been watching it with
friends and having a beer and just
riffing off of each other like if I
would have watched this with the walkers
and Malcolm and Walter and Heather
nayana it would have just been so much
again I had a blast with it but it's one
of those movies that you want to watch
the friends then go and make stuff with
friends right after you will laugh
heartily at the Gandhi skit Gandhi - no
more passive resistance better than it
needs to be my god yes
just so much better than I was expecting
and I think I was expecting it to be
good
but this was hilarious oh man I'm so
glad you're doing this one I spent my
childhood watching it and still randomly
quote it till this day
bad news badgers we don't need for
stinking badgers I don't know what the
badges quotas from but I've seen that
movie because I distinctly remember that
woman saying badges we don't need no
stinking badges and so I love love the
cause of that there were so many calls
and inside jokes from movies and I
wonder how many of them just went
straight over my head because I just
don't know anything you want to smack
whoever thought misogynistic ads were a
laughing matter what better way to say I
love you than the gift of the spatula I
don't know I hope that didn't bother me
I don't think that wasn't saga mystic I
think it was hilarious though I will say
I think this probably wouldn't be made
today there were a lot of jokes like the
supplies and like him having like the Ku
Klux Klan on his talk show shirt yeah
probably probably wouldn't be maids day
don't love the Ku Klux Klan hate him but
overall I do it did a good job of not
going over the line of offensive it was
just it was fun it was funny you'll
wonder why there's an entire music video
just slapped in the middle of the movie
yeah that would be pull me
rude that was the only part of the movie
that just really didn't vibe well didn't
flow well I guess it starts slow but
Stanley helps pick it up yeah I wasn't
really sure how I was going to feel
about this movie I thought it might
start dragging but man it picks up and
it was so good I had so much fun with
that
and if I try that sandwich I will put it
on my youtube channel so subscribe there
thank you so much to the person who sent
me this movie and suggested it and thank
you so much for all your suggestions
I really do read them and I don't know
what's coming up next week so leave it
mom I quit thank you for watching I will
see you all next week what's up and bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you